[Musique]
vous êtes sur France 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique à la une ce soir le boycott
remarqué des producteurs africains de
cacao à Bruxelles pour le sommet qui
réunit les partenaires de la Fondation
mondiale de cacao Accra et Abidjan
protestent contre le fait que les
multinationales du secteur refuse
toujours d'augmenter une prime versée
aux producteurs de cacao nous irons dès
le début de ce journal à Accra
nous irons au risque aussi à Maurice sur
le probable assassinat d'un militant de
la coalition au pouvoir l'agent
politique était sur le point de révéler
des pratiques de corruption ou de fraude
électorales deux ans après les faits les
conclusions de l'enquête judiciaire sont
accablantes pour la police et embarrasse
le pouvoir reportage à suivre
et en ce mois d'octobre nous poursuivons
notre sensibilisation contre le cancer
du sein un fléau qui ravage le continent
africain c'est la première ou la
deuxième cause de mortalité et du cancer
du sein chez les femmes dans la plupart
des pays africains nous irons en Afrique
du Sud à la rencontre de tato une femme
qui vit avec un cancer du sein et a dû
subir une ablation de son sein dans un
contexte social difficile une ONG aide
les patientes à accepter la maladie et
son traitement
on ouvre ce journal par ce coup de
tonnerre dans le ciel déjà orageux des
relations entre les producteurs de cacao
et les multinationales occidentales la
Côte d'Ivoire et le Ghana qui représente
65% de la production mondiale de cacao
et ne perçoivent pourtant que 6% des
revenus ont décidé de boycotter le
sommet de Bruxelles qui s'est ouvert ce
mercredi et pour en parler on rejoint
Accra alexandrew le secrétaire exécutif
de l'initiative cacao Côte d'Ivoire
Ghana merci Monsieur Asan Vaud de nous
rejoindre sur France 24 dites nous déjà
pourquoi avoir pris cette décision de
boycotter cette réunion qui est pourtant
très importante pour votre secteur
merci Madame ben tout d'abord clairement
cela montre que les pays membres de
l'Organisation donc la Côte d'Ivoire le
Ghana ne sont pas contents donc cela a
été une réaction pour nous pour donner
un message très fort
aux membres de l'industrie mais aussi
cela aussi montre une frustration nous
avons il y a quelques mois et vous
l'avez vous-même couvert il y a trois
mois de bonnes discussions avec
l'industrie très constructive pour
sortir de certaines situations que nous
avait été décelés sur la mise en place
d'un mécanisme de prix que la Côte
d'Ivoire et le Ghana avait mis en place
mais vous voyez
aujourd'hui la prime pays lorsque elle
est altérée impacte directement le prix
final au producteur donc ceci a une
conséquence immédiate sur des millions
de producteurs et pour nous la Côte
d'Ivoire et le Ghana il est important
aujourd'hui de ne pas accepter et c'est
un message pour nous de protestation
et alors il y a vouloir vous le rappeler
un trentaine et vous nous expliquer
justement que les discussions avancées
bien notamment sur sur cette question de
prix avec entre les producteurs de cacao
et justement les industriels du chocolat
aujourd'hui finalement qu'est-ce que
vous demandez le contexte a changé une
prise en compte une meilleure prise en
compte finalement du contexte économique
global
mais en effet comme vous le voyez tous
aujourd'hui partout il y a des
situations d'inflation de crise
économique et nous l'avons constaté
aujourd'hui le chocolat par exemple son
prix qui a augmenté de presque 6 en 6 et
8%. et l'une des raisons c'est
l'augmentation de du lait du sucre
disons de la betterave qui est utilisé
pour faire du sucre et plus les autres
produits qui sont produits en Occident
mais malheureusement dans cette
situation nous voyons que le cacao
depuis plusieurs mois les prix du marché
nous montrent un cacao qui baisse et en
termes de valeur cela n'est pas du tout
normal surtout lorsqu'on voit que des
intrants et d'autres produits utilisés
dans nos pays ont augmenté nous
considérons que cela ne joue pas dans le
partenariat que nous avons créé et
surtout les accords que nous avons eu
avec l'industrie il y a quelques mois
donc nous nous demandons quand même
qu'on revoit tout cela bien sûr c'est
une question de marché mais le marché ne
peut pas être la réponse à tout
et donc cette création pour nous va nous
demander de revoir certaines choses
autant avec l'industrie car tous les
partenaires avec qui nous travaillons
alors notre sujet qui émerge de ces
conversations et tout autour du cacao
durable donc plus éthique biologique qui
respecte les normes environnementales et
finalement là-dessus non plus vous avez
un point de désaccord
oui le désaccord est très fort tout
d'abord nous la Côte d'Ivoire et le
Ghana nous avons mené beaucoup d'efforts
vous l'avez vu récemment il y avait
plusieurs annonces la Côte d'Ivoire a
mis en place un programme de traçabilité
nationale ainsi qu'au Ghana nous avons
plusieurs activités en Côte d'Ivoire le
lancement d'une stratégie nationale pour
le cacao durable au plus haut niveau et
pareil au Ghana nous avons plusieurs
actions qui sont menées la mise en place
d'un standard point cacao durable pour
tous les producteurs et le mécanisme de
prix mais parallèlement nous constatons
que nous sommes assujettis à un marché
ce marché qui est la couverture de tout
aujourd'hui le marché ne prend pas en
compte toutes les externalités qui sont
demandées autour de la durabilité c'est
très grave parce que lorsqu'on entend
aujourd'hui des régulations qui se
mettent en place et tout cela n'est pas
du tout en lien puisque comment est-ce
qu'on peut avoir de la durabilité la
durabilité c'est trois piliers ces trois
piliers
c'est le pilier économique le pilier
social et environnemental donc du coup
lorsque la partie économique n'est pas
du tout prise en compte alors que elle
elle est connectée au deux autres
piliers clairement et un problème nous
voyons des annonces de programmes de
durabilité de l'industrie de plusieurs
millions de dollars mais par contre le
prix un an on peut pas toucher seulement
marché il est temps qu'on revoit tout
cela donc aujourd'hui notre message à
nous c'est de dire nous sommes
producteurs de pays de cacao mais
il est temps de revoir certaines
mécanismes et ces mécanismes nous
discutons avant que l'industrie donc la
porte n'est pas fermée mais par contre
nous allons réagir aujourd'hui toute
entreprise qui se permettra d'annoncer
des programmes de durabilité et serait
associé automatiquement à ce genre de
manipulation vers les prix bas et
surtout de manipulations envers depuis
très très bas surtout de la prime de
qualité verrons le programme de
durabilité revue alors seulement
suspendu alors dites nous monsieur à
sandre vos rapidement mais où on est
cette question finalement que tout le
monde se pose sur à quand un marché
local qui va valoriser et qui va traiter
finalement le cacao parce que aussi il y
a cette question de d'avoir un marché
local qui est fort qui est puissant qui
sera moins dépendant évidemment des
transformations faites à l'étranger
finalement en dehors du continent
africain
bien sûr je pense que déjà la première
des choses c'est que tous nous devons
manger un peu plus de chocolat mais en
plus de cela nous regardons aussi tous
les produits dérivés du cacao et nous
avons aujourd'hui plusieurs axes de
réflexion comme la zone de libre-échange
africaine qui nous permettra de
diversifier des sites de production dans
la région avec des moyens de transport
exemple de plusieurs taxes donc afin de
faciliter tout cela donc oui il nous
faut consommer plus de chocolat nous
sommes pas une région de consommation de
chocolat mais ça va être au travail de
tous non nous devons nous y mettre
absolument le pari est pris merci
beaucoup monsieur à son beau merci
d'être venu sur ce journal là
on passe à l'Ouganda qui intensifie son
action contre la propagation du virus
Ébola les autorités ont annoncé la mise
en test de candidats vaccins dans les
deux semaines le virus a atteint la
capitale et commence à créer la panique
même si les services de santé régionaux
ont déclaré que la situation était sous
contrôle les précisions de Laurent
un mois après le début de l'épidémie le
virus Ébola continue de se propager en
Ouganda les autorités sanitaires
annoncent l'ouverture d'un sixième
centre de traitement et la mise en place
des sectes cliniques de vaccins contre
le variant soudanais
évaluer l'efficacité de trois candidats
vaccins sur les cas contacts dans les
semaines à venir et notamment leur
capacité à protéger jusqu'à 29 jours
après le contact avec un patient Ebola
depuis le début de l'épidémie l'Ouganda
surveille de très près les contacts
d'environ 150 personnes ayant contracté
le virus près de 3000 cas contacts ont
ainsi été identifiés et doivent
maintenant prendre part aux essais
cliniques censés débuter d'ici deux
semaines alors que les autorités
assurent toujours maîtrisé la situation
l'épidémie s'est récemment propagée vers
la capitale Kampala avec 15k confirmés
certains habitants redoutent aujourd'hui
un confinement similaire à celui imposé
durant l'épidémie de covid-19 mais
d'autres disent faire confiance à
l'expérience des autorités pour
contrôler le virus il n'y a pas eu de
confinement pendant les épidémies
précédentes donc ça m'étonnerait qu'il y
en ait un maintenant nous avons plus de
ressources les gens sont mieux informés
qu'avant nous allons mieux gérer cette
fois
ces dernières années les vaccins ont
démontré leur efficacité dans la lutte
contre Ebola notamment en RDC mais aucun
n'a pour l'instant été approuvé pour
lutter contre le variant soudanais qui
s'évite actuellement en Ouganda
des milliers de soudanés ont manifesté à
cartoon contre le pouvoir militaire
installé par un pucc il y a un an et en
mémoire des victimes de la répression la
police a attiré des grenades
lacrymogènes sur les manifestants le
Soudan ne cesse de s'enfoncer dans la
crise politique alors que la chute du
dictateur
omarelle bécher en 2019 avait laissé
entrevoir l'espoir d'un renouveau
l'autre sujet de l'actualité c'est cette
affaire politique à Maurice il y a deux
ans mourait un militant du parti au
pouvoir alors qu'il était sur le point
de révéler des pratiques de corruption
et de fraude électorale les conclusions
de l'enquête judiciaire sur un probable
assassinat politique jette le blâme sur
le pouvoir et embarrasse fortement le
pouvoir reportage de notre correspondant
Abdoulaye
2 ans de faire son deuil chaque jour
cette femme au foyer vient
religieusement honorer la mémoire de son
époux un militant d'un parti politique
au pouvoir décédé alors qu'il
s'apprêtait à dénoncer des pratiques de
corruption et de fraude électorale
il était très en colère il m'a dit je
n'en peux plus de leur comportement ils
se sont servis de moi je vais les
dénoncer à la commission anticorruption
cet homme de 52 ans très actif dans la
circonscription du Premier ministre
législatif de 2019 disparaît alors
pendant 2 jours avant d'être retrouvé
mort ici a-t-elle faire dans un champ de
cannes l'empressement de la police a
classé l'affaire attisera les soupçons
d'un probable assassinat cet ancien
détective de la police mauricienne
critique une enquête bâclée et orientée
les règles bases n'ont pas été suivies
un policier à même dit la femme de la
victime que c'était un cas de suicide
quand le toxine n'avait pas encore été
pratiqué la police scientifique n'avait
pas encore fait des prélèvements une
jeune magistrate de cette cour de
justice sera saisie de l'affaire
cependant son rapport d'enquête est
resté confidentielle et sans suite
pendant un an jusqu'à ce que cette
télévision en ligne en révèle les
conclusions accablantes jamais la
justice mauricienne n'a été aussi sévère
envers la police qualifiée
d'incompétente lamentable voire odieuse
pour la justice la mort du chef agent
électoral est fortement suspecte et se
meurtre ne serait pas étranger aux
pratiques frauduleuses qu'il s'apprêtait
à dénoncer ce nouveau rebondissement a
provoqué une énorme émotion dans le pays
ces manifestants laissé éclater leur
indignation devant le siège du
gouvernement à Port-Louis monsieur
l'agence n'est pas nous qu'il faut
déloger mais le corrompu qui parle en ce
moment au Parlement le Premier ministre
pravine de jognotte affirme que la
police enquête bien que les forces de
l'ordre et la commission anticorruption
dépendent de son bureau l'enquête
n'avance pas qui doit mener les
investigations faut-il que les services
du Premier ministre soient décisif de
cette affaire pour éviter tout soupçon
ce sont des questions que l'on se pose à
Maurice
l'Afrique du Sud a regretté cette alerte
sur un risque d'attentat à Johannesbourg
diffusé ce mercredi par l'ambassade des
États-Unis Pretoria juge cette annonce
malencontreuse car susceptible de créer
la panique est né en fait l'objet
d'aucune discussion préalable
on reste en Afrique du Sud pour parler
du cancer du sein un fléau qui touche de
nombreuses femmes mais au-delà des
moyens scientifiques disponibles pour
détecter et traiter les facteurs
psychologiques retard de souvent le
traitement c'est pourquoi une petite ONG
de Johannesbourg forme des conseillers
psychologiques pour aider des patients à
accepter la maladie reportage de
Caroline Dumet Nadine Théron et Stéphane
karsen
tatto vit avec le cancer depuis deux ans
elle a dû se faire enlever le sein droit
l'an dernier son moral est bon grâce à
cette fondation qui soutient le patient
sa rémission n'a pas du réel a repris la
chimiothérapie le lundi précédent notre
rencontre et les effets secondaires tu
les as senti
non non pour l'instant en tout cas je me
sens bien
tattoo n'a même pas encore parlé de sa
récidive à sa fille de 13 ans
la maladie est revenue je ne l'ai pas
encore dit à ma fille elle va stresser à
ce sujet il faut que je lui trouve
quelqu'un qui parlait qui pourrait la
conseiller quelqu'un qui comprenne ma
situation
on comprend ce que l'on ressent quand on
a une opération de ce type parce qu'on
l'a tout vécu
nous-mêmesctomie à 17 ans
OMA a eu la sienne en 2015 tato va aussi
perdre son sein gauche instructrice de
fitness elle vit dans sa salle de gym
comme si de rien n'était
je me balade dans les douches avec un
seul sein et les clientes de la salle de
fitness les femmes qui ne me connaissent
pas elle regarde ma poitrine avec un
seul sein et elle se dise waouh c'est ça
le cancer on peut perdre un sein mais on
continue à vivre on peut même être très
heureuse on est parfois un peu timide on
se dit je n'ai plus de poitrine mais
c'est juste un saint il n'est plus là
mais votre vie est bien là
l'astigmatisation est importante en zone
rurale beaucoup de femmes malades
pensent qu’on leur a jeté un sort en ce
moment nous avons une patiente de 22 ans
sa mère lui a demandé pourquoi sa
poitrine avait soudainement enflé d'où
vient le problème mais la fille est
convaincue que c'est la famille du petit
ami qui ensorcelé
je pense qu'on a vraiment besoin
d'informer le public et pas seulement au
mois d'octobre il faut en parler toute
l'année allez dans les communautés où
nous pourrions transmettre des
informations
éduquer avec la fin du covid cette
fondation reprendra bientôt ses
activités hors des grandes villes si sa
santé le permet Tato se promenait d'y
aller
c'est la fin de ce journal d'Afrique
merci à tous ceux qui nous ont suivi
[Musique]